hello everyone I hope you're having an
excellent Sunday because this game I'm
about to show you will I'm sure further
improve it and I'm very very happy that
I'm able to show you this game it's just
it's really just a wonderful game like a
movie really a lot of things are
happening this happens that happens then
this guy misses this this guy misses
that and well you can't really tell
what's going on at some point but it's
super exciting a lot of theory into the
game and well let's just enjoy it we do
have some refreshed profile photos
compliments of niki riga and i know what
you're gonna say why are you always
using a weird photo of a new pony shape
yeah but that's just the thing there's
no casual or some sort of a normal
profile photo of nipple available online
it's just not possible a lot of
photographers have tried to get a nice
profile photo of nipple but no one no
one was able to do it so far neppo is
always either just are you know touching
his face or or making faces and it's
just very difficult to get well a normal
photo of him here are some examples well
not dad but obviously here you can see
that well it's a nice photo but still
not your well the profile photo you
would want also there's this one here
again a very nice photo but i mean yeah
i hope you understand what i'm talking
about and here we have also a nice photo
of nipple just you know fixing the
volume he's sorry about that and you
know the game started as you can see he
has the white pieces and he's he's very
happy about something but yeah that
being said i mean if you don't believe
me go online and try to find a nice
profile photo of nepo it's simply not
not possible but you know we work with
what we have so without further ado
let's check out the game napa verse 11
oregon first round of the grand prix
2019 let's let's just enjoy it we have E
4 E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 again we have the real opus
so again not getting all that far away
from the capo Blanca stock still
everything is just Queen's Gambit the
client and the real opus with a 6 more
fees defense butts up to a 492 f6 now we
have castles by Neto Bishop to e7 and
just rook to you
the standard line will be five bishop
back to be 3 and now castles and it's
interesting Ireland had this position
with the black pieces several times he
had it in this year's a Greinke chess
classic I had it against Fabiano Caruana
and also against Maximo Cheryl Grove
Corwin I tried c3 here in this position
that game ended in a draw and Maxine was
Sheila Grove a 4 here also the game
ended didn't draw so nipple decides to
go for the for the third line we have d4
we have well here you're basically going
for pawn captures Indy 500 nadou525 it's
India tournament and Hari Krishna won
that game against Oregon after 98 he
continued with c3 a very active line but
the nipple probably thought that well
not in a bar and I thought that nipple
probably had this all in his preparation
and he he went for a different line
after d4 first he played Knight captures
on d4 and then we have Knight captures
on d4 e capture son d4 and now II five
nights to e8 and now c3 so this is a
sorry I forgot that that this is the
line that he had against the Hari
Krishna in last year's a blitz
tournament in the Tata Steel India
Edition and Hari Krishna won't that
again but here nipple
actually prepared a different line after
this Knight captures on d4 by Oregon
he doesn't capture here but rather he
plays it Bishop captures on f7 and it's
just just a nice line that offers a lot
of possibilities it's not a new move but
it has been played before some in some
75 games in the database but it's just
very exciting we have rook captures on
f7 Knight captures on e5 now threatening
to grab the rook but also now the night
is indefinite so Queen captures on d4 is
a possibility and here I know what
you're thinking why not just move back
the night and 96 and then but you give
up the rook for two pieces nice capture
screen captures and black is just you
know very happy to pieces for a look and
it would be the case if white didn't
have a win by by force here just see
five who wins the game
white as you would have to give up the
night back and then you just be down the
exchange and if you don't want to give
up the night if you just move it let's
say here then Queen to f3 check we'll
just pick up the rook and then white is
of course completely winning
so after this Knight captures on e5 with
rook to f8 the MU debt has always been
played in this line Queen captures Sundy
for grabbing back the piece and now
Bishop to b7 just you know developing
putting the bishop to a very nice
diagonal with Knight to c3 now
developing also increasing the defense
of the e4 pawn and now c5 this move is
the standard move in this position Queen
to d1 and now comes b4 forcing the
Knights to move with Knight to d5 Knight
captures on d5 e captures on d5 and now
Bishop to d6 and here this position has
been reached I believe four times so far
in the database the most notable game is
Bassam I mean Egyptian Grandmaster
versus Peter lecco in the 2011 World
Team Championship where f4 was played
but here Knepper goes for c4 it's a new
move in this position and it is the the
engine stop recommendation so I believe
nipple came fully prepared to play this
line against 11 so 11 of course doesn't
isn't interested in allowing nipple to
keep this very strong center so he
eliminates the c4 pawn will be captures
on c4 ampersand B captures on c3 and not
a5 with ideas of maybe bringing the
bishop over to this diagonal also maybe
the rook can come into the game this way
just a lot of ideas are possible Knight
back to f3 and now comes the Queen to f6
just putting pressure on the c3 pawn and
now push up the g5 here you have to move
the Queen we have Queen to g6
and now comes Bishop to e7 and here
black has to decide whether he wants to
capture or he wants to play rook to f7 a
fluke to f7
then you get Bishop captures Queen
captures and again white gets the close
to this very nice central structure with
c4 and Aragon isn't interested in this
after Bishop capture after Bishop e7 we
have Bishop captures on e7 rook captures
on e7 and now Queen to d6 just attacking
the rook and putting well the d5 pawn
under pressure is now the Queen end of
the super
attacking it you can't prevent black
from grabbing both so we have to go
Queen to e2 and now well you are winning
a pawn but you can't play Queen captures
because rook to d1 is just too strong
after you move the Queen now you get
rook D capture some d7 and there's just
too much pressure here going on on the
Kings side even if the bishop capture
series just gonna capture on g7 king day
h8 and I are gonna capture here Queen
captures and Queen to e5 check King here
now we're gonna grab the Queen and even
though you do have two looks for a queen
the white that white is up three points
you're gonna eliminate all the other
points very quickly the the black king
is you know bare naked here so we're
gonna able to do a lot of checks and
black will not be able to to play this
out so after Queen to e2 we have Bishop
character son d4 and d5 sorry and now
comes Luke to d1 11 goes rook 8 w8 just
a nice active move with the rook and now
it seems like c4 would win your material
here but it really doesn't just Bishop
captures an f3 and you're even forced to
capture it with the Jeep on as you have
to keep an eye on the e7 rook so not
really not really something you want to
do Queen g6 and you haven't really
achieved anything
so after Luke 8 to b8 with 91 not
allowing this capture and f3 also the
knight is now nicely defending the g2
pawn we have Queen to c6 putting
pressure on the sea to pawn also getting
the Queen out of this nasty D file and
now comes Queen to e5 and it's a very
nice move
threatening to either win the bishop or
deliver checkmate which is of course
even better and you can't defend with
this or other words you're getting
checkmate this we have to play Bishop to
f7 it's the best defensive move and here
we have rook captures and e7 i Levin had
to allow this so now there's well and
it's never Pleasant to have white bring
both of his rooks of up to the seventh
rank as now you're it's gonna be pretty
hard to find any activity but 11 find
that we have looked after eh
now you can capture or otherwise you
lose the Queen so here but it's
important to show that after rook
captures rook captures here there is no
checkmate for example rook captures King
here you can get rook f7 check King here
and now if York was protected yes then
Ruby it would be checkmate but here it's
just not and you don't
have a good follow up here you're just
losing rook here is coming the other
rope is coming to a 1v1 completely
winning for black so we have Queen to f4
nappa now threatens to win the f7 Bishop
and then deliver checkmate on g7 but now
just Queen to f6 offering a trade we
have rook captures with Czech rook
captures and now comes Queen back to d2
just defending the knight the night here
and also well keeping control of the D
file defending the c3 pawn and just
continuing the game with Queen to e6
threatening checkmate after Queen
captures anyone and now rook the d8
stopping checkmate offering to trade
rooks now of course this is pointless as
you're unable to deliver checkmate your
Lucas pin you would have to capture and
then it's of course the Queen against
rook and Bishop white would be winning
here so after route to d8 we have h6
just making some room for the king so no
back rank and mate idea sir or possible
we have rook captures sorry rook
captures with Czech Queen captures with
Czech and now just a three not allowing
this pawn to remain a target na do you
know after all is said and done you have
this position where both players have
three point islands but nipple is up a
pawn but on the other hand it's a you
know the game is being played on both
sides of the board so a bishop should be
a little bit better but in this case
both of Naples pawns are already and
dark squares so the bishop will not be
all that impressive you know in in
pretty much doing anything on the Queen
side at least we have Queen to a 411 now
finds a very nice plan he wants to play
Queen to b3 butcher of g6 Bishop c2
block if the Queen retreats the c1 which
the Queen will the Queen will have then
a clear idea of winning the c3 pawn but
you know Queen c1 why it has to defend
both the a3 ended the c3 pawn and now
Bush up to g6 continuing with the plan
we have Knight to f3 by Napo Queen to b3
now threatening Bishop to c2 to win at
least one of the pawns and now Knights
the e5 attacking the bishop the bishop
the sea tube and now just Knight to g4
trying to trick Aragon
if 11 now characters here then of course
Knight to the e3 just attach the pin
piece you would you would lose a bishop
here so after Knight to g4 with a
by Oregon and not just h3 also creating
some breathing room for the king push up
the back to f5 and here in a process
nope my night is much better than your
Bishop while both of my pawns on Queen
on the Queen side around our squares
we're not trading here with Knight to e5
and now comes King to h7 and here just
came to H to a much safer Square for the
King Queen to a - now that the F do pawn
is vulnerable and now King back to g1
never decides it's better it's better if
you just stay there we have King to g8
and now comes a very nice move by neppo
Queen to f4 and it's a beautiful move
attacking the bishop on f5 but also
threatening Queen to c4 check which
would trade Queens and then you will
just go into a knight against Bishop
endgame where white is up upon so here
you have to decide either you're gonna
go back Bishop c2 then we go to this
check captures captures and then well
it's again both of the points on the
Queen's that are on dark squares so no
light square bishop not really a big
deal here and white will just have a
very nice game bring bring the King into
the game and then well it's just much
better for white if not winning by by
force but probably it is winning for
white so after Queen to f4 11 isn't
interested in playing this much worse
end game against nip oh so he decides to
go for Queen captures on a3 he decides
to give up the knight the bishop for the
to put two points and create two best
points on the Queen side with Queen
captures on f5 Queen captures on c3 and
now is it's a very important moment in
the game because here you have a chance
to end the game on the spot but it's a
really a really a crazy idea so I mean I
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find it as it is a nice Sunday
but never went for a different idea but
still yeah you're welcome to pause the
video and try to find this forcing line
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
supporter of disgusting engine alliance
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
quinta east sex is the idea never went
with Knight to c6 and he brought the
night over to the Queen site to prevent
the past points from being pushed but
here Quinta e6 is winning by force came
to h8 you can go to f8
it's going to f son would be checkmate
now you get Knight to g6 check King to
h7 and now Queen to d8 this is the setup
you have to remember if you for some
reason encounter it in your own games
now it's a you don't have time to put
any pass bonds because here it's
important to realize that after let's
say queen c1 king h2 there's no Queen f4
check to continue harassing the white
king because the night covers the f4
square so it's a really important setup
that I'm sure you will find it very
useful if if you have a similar position
in your own games then you will know oh
okay this position is winning I don't
even have to you know calculate anything
a whites plan is very clear the Queen to
h8 would be checkmate if the night on g6
was defended so here the point is f4
after black makes any move it's like I
said it's you don't have time to put any
points you have to play Queen c4 to at
least hope and hope to trade Queens but
then just f4 also nice Knight nicely
protects the pawn and here if f5 that
will protect the night Queen 2h it will
be checkmate so here you would have to
try and trade Queens but now Queen to e4
and now you threaten a lot of nasty
discoveries the king has nowhere to go
any move by Knight threatens a nasty
discovery you have to move the Queen 97
check would forcefully win the Queen and
it's important you can go to d8 sorry to
eat or to a 8 to guard your a4 pawn
because the Queen from efore guards the
e8 square and also the a squares so this
is a really just crazy and I would have
to move the Queen not to lose it and
then just 95 check you move the King and
then you win da for pawn so basically
this entire line if black wants to
prevent checkmate he has to give up the
e4 pawn and now there's no counter play
from black now we have just one passed
pawn and it's never crossing the c-4
square so now it's completely winning
for white so this is one idea that white
could have used here but like I said
it's a disgusting engine line Knepper
tries a different one Knight to c6 and
now well of course if a3 this is the
point and then 97 just the delivers
checkmate King h8 check here King gauge
7 Queen - GA - checkmate
add the the g6 where it's covered by the
night this was
cause idea so kink th8 now Ireland tries
to trick nipple now just nice to e7 of
course queenie one check who will pick
up the night so black would be winning
here so you have to be very careful we
have Queen to f7 now preparing Knight to
e7 and here we have Queen to b3 and now
Oregon offers to trade Queens as then of
course black would be winning so 28
check King to h7 Queen to b4 check King
to a trade and our just Knights the a5
attacking the Queen Queen to d1 check
King to h2 and now comes Queen to d6
check and here F for a useful move with
a 3 now getting that passed pawn rollin
with Queen to a for attacking it and now
c4 again trying to trying to trick him
if you capture with the night then you
no longer defend the DF for pawn the
Queen no longer defends it now you
you're able to draw by force I hear it
would be just you know draw by perpetual
check Kim Ji Won you could go Quincey
one check King h2 queen a four check and
so on and so on if you block then just
check check check and check
it's not really not really possible to
to defend this so after this c4 move
with Queen captures in c4 and now with
Queen to d2 attacking the knight here on
a five nights the b3 and now Queen to
III so still keeping his past a three
pawn it's a very dangerous pawn and
hoping that it will be enough to hold
the wrong and snip oh we have Knights
the c1 now as the queen guards the night
and c1 and also both the Queen and the
night guard the a2 square there's really
no chance for this a point to ever cross
the a2 square but it's hard to say if a
white will have enough resources term at
the window to win the game as both to
the Queen and the night are forced the
guard the a2 square so with h5 now comes
h4 by White Queen to e7 going for the h4
pawn and now Queen the CA to check with
King to h7 Queen to f5 check g6 and now
Queen all the way to h3
defending the h4 pawn but also
pressuring the a3 point if the Queen
ever moves from this diagonal with Queen
to f7 now going after the
for point and now neppo decides to go
for a crazy line but you know it's it
doesn't matter if it's crazy if it works
here he pushes f5 which is really crazy
as it allows the Queen to c7 check which
would pick up the night and c1 but here
a nipple just makes it work or or or
does he maybe he doesn't Queen c7 check
has played win g3 blocking and
threatening Queen captures and g6 we
have Queen captures on c1 Queen captures
and G sex with check King to h8 and now
Queen captures on h5 again with check
eliminating both of these pawns King g7
Queen g6 check we have came to f8 and
here if you try f6 to end the game
immediately it's not enough as Queen to
f4 would again ensure black a draw by
repetition
kim jiwon you could go Queen III check
King H - you could go Queen a4 check
sorry Queen a4 check if King H 3 then
again Queen III check King g4 you could
go Queen a6 check and now you have to go
back if you're if you're persistent and
if you decide to go forward then you can
even lose the game after Queen 2 g8 now
you would have to trade Queens and then
of course the black pawn Queens much
faster so now King to a fate with Queen
to f6 check Napo tries to create
something King to a king to 8 Queens the
e6 check King to f8 Queen to d6 check
King to f7 Quinta ESX check King to have
faith alone is very happy with a draw
here Queen to f6 check King to g8 and
now Queen to e5 and here well sorry that
now you already seen it but the this was
one moment where 11 could have taken his
chance to to actually draw the game
because here he has a chance to make one
move and in the game he played King to
f7 just allowing white to push f6 after
f6 the game is over but here if he
played Queen to h6 it would have allowed
allowed him to grab a draw because here
the h4 pawn is under attack and there's
no way to to to go further if if Queen
g3 check then you just move the King
there are no more checking ID I mean
there are but you can just go back and
forth and if f6
then the point is after Queen captures
an a4 check King Jiwon now you play a
and now as the Queen covers the f2
square if the Queen moves from here then
a 1 will be checkmate so you have to be
very careful here after Queen e8 check
King h7 you could go Queen f7 check King
to h6 and now Queen g7 check King to h5
and now even if you go f7 you're still
guarding the a1 square with the Queen
but now black has a perpetual 21
checking h2 Queen h4 check King g1 Queen
e2 check and so on but after Queenie 511
plays King to f7 and now neppo just has
a winning game he played f6 now the
point is too advanced we have Queen to
c4 and now comes Queen to e7 check King
to g6 we have Queen to g7 check King to
f5 Queen to g5 check and it was in this
position unmoved 72 that 11 Arjen
resigned the game and an excellent went
for for an apology in this round one of
the feet of Grand Prix 2019 why did you
resign well there are two moves you can
go for either King g6 or King g4 if you
go King e6 then Queen g8 wins the Queen
as you have to move the King somewhere
and on the other hand if you go King to
e4 then you get Queen g4 check King d5
and just captures after King captures f7
by goes a2 and you will bring a queen
into the game black will do the same but
now it's a queen opponent game where
white is up two points of course
everyone was it's a completely winning
endgame for white so 11 not interested
in even trying to go for some tricks
here maybe maybe maybe young will
blunder maybe you know he will be able
to grab a stalemate or something he's
not interested he resigns as this was
from game 1 but in game 2 that ended in
a draw so with this win a young pony she
basically eliminate 11 Oregon from the
feeder Grand Prix 2019 at least from the
from the first part and I will mention
some of the standings here as I
mentioned we already seen a game
Donald uber versus onigiri first game
between Duke and Geary ended in a draw
but then the second game do but one and
he eliminated onigiri from from the
Grand Prix at a job of and Nakamura drew
both of their games or they are going
into rapid tiebreaks today in there
they are being played as we speak yeah
she stuff do the action of Luda and
Wesley so well dude I won the first game
and he only needed a draw in the second
game but he bravely played the Sicilian
against Wesley and Wesley was able to
win the second one so he's also in the
tiebreaks against Wesley Alexander
Grisha was able to eliminate Sergei
kurakin after drawing first and winning
the second game and as we already
mentioned the any Pony she eliminated
eleven Oregon after well this game that
we've just seen way E eliminated Dmitry
avantco and Peter Svidler eliminated
Nikita B cube of he drew the first game
then Svidler won the second one and one
of the more important games and quite an
upset
rather avoid a chick who won his first
game against Chartier mama D are off
even though he was much worse he was
able to turn it around and win the game
and then he was able to draw the second
game against a mommy DRF so for the
moment we know that slipper will face
rather Slavic in the second part of the
video Grand Prix and an opponent she
will face way E and the other well the
other pairings are unknown as well they
are still going into the rapids so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you've enjoyed this little info
I brought you now I would like to thank
Stephen Mills na Garcinia Russian
Vignesh Nicolas pain Gregory Stewart and
Adrian's Arcola for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos you're thinking for watching and
I will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content from the video
Grand Prix containing the capablanca
saga and of course checking up on your
suggestions thank you all I will see you
soon have an excellent rest of your
Sunday